i thought these were an urban shoe myth
oh
it's not a myth it's a fact sarah
jessica parker is stepping back into
carrie bradshaw's fabulous
designer shoes for a sex in the city
revival
to do some episodes of sex in the city i
wouldn't call it a reboot i would just
call it a revisit
but will kim cattrall be back to play
samantha
exactly what we needed three single gals
back on the camp
sjp teased the new series for hbo max on
social media on
sunday sharing this clip featuring
scenes from new york city
and someone typing carrie bradshaw's
style on the computer
and just like that the story continues
and just like that
the caption i couldn't help but wonder
where are they now
of course fans of sex and the city know
sarah jessica parker was quoting her
famous character
i started to wonder and i wondered which
led me to wonder
i had to wonder and naturally fans of
the iconic show
lost their damn minds
and i'm deaf i'm so excited cynthia
nixon who played miranda on the series
and kristen davis who played charlotte
also shared the teaser on instagram and
e.t
can confirm they'll be joining sarah
jessica in the new series titled
drum roll please and just like that
i think carrie bradshaw would be just so
greedy to have to share her feelings and
thoughts
oh and get this the ladies will also be
executive producers on the series that
will include
10 half-hour episodes alongside original
series ep
michael patrick king that's scheduled to
begin production in new york this spring
i'd like to see yeah where all of them
are i mean the world has changed so much
it's changed with tech technology and
social media
those characters never talked about
social media which i just think would be
really interesting
and just also sexual politics and the
metoo movement and time's up
has you know been really steered
conversations about sexual politics
if i end up old and alone it's all your
fault oh charlotte sweetie we're all
alone
so i know what you're thinking where's
sam
i love you but i love me more kim
cattrall who played
samantha jones in the original series
has been vocal over the last few years
about
not wanting to bring back her character
for any future projects
i remember so clearly
making that decision and
last december i got a phone call and it
was concerning that
and the answer was simply thank you
but no well on sunday while replying to
fans on instagram
sarah jessica appeared to confirm kim
was out
on the new series when one fan wrote
quote happy to see you back but we'll
miss
kim samantha she responded quote we will
too
we loved her so sjp replied to another
fan who also wrote about missing
samantha
writing she will always be there and we
are so excited
whether we get to tell another chapter
of that story
i don't know we'll see ya she also shot
down rumors of a feud with kim
after a fan accused sjp of disliking her
former co-star
sjp set the record straight insisting
quote
no i don't dislike her i've never said
that
never would samantha isn't part of this
story but she will always be part of
us no matter where we are or what we do
of course this all comes after kim gave
an interview to the mail
online in 2019 where she said she would
quote
never return to her iconic role quote
it's a no from me
you learn lessons in life and my lesson
is to do work with
good people and try and make it fun
awkward while kim is out cynthia and
kristen replied to a comment from their
co-star willie garson
who plays carrie's bestie stanford
blatch leading fans to wonder if
he'll also be making a return hello you
[Music]
hello you as for mr big
i kind of think that story is told many
times
i think it's over chris noth told et he
was done in 2017
but when sjp was asked about her
on-screen hubby
she simply replied wait and see
i missed you i missed you
[Music]
you